hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so I'm about three months
into this mothering game and I am
definitely learning a lot it is an
ongoing struggle and one of the things
that I personally have been finding
really challenging is this whole work
baby balance
I am a working mom
aka a mompreneurs some people like to
call them though I really just like to
see myself as like those two things
happening simultaneously I'm a mom and
I'm a working woman we don't need to
have a specific class of working women
necessarily but I know that's what
people like to call us on the internet
and you know it's it's a struggle it's
so hard I mean and one of the things
that I find so difficult about it is the
overwhelming amount of guilt that I feel
every single day no matter what no
matter what I'm doing I feel guilty when
like my nanny or my husband has to feed
my baby a bottle because I'm shooting a
YouTube video like right now and I feel
guilty when I'm taking my kid for like a
two-hour walk in the middle of a workday
just to get him to sleep for a minute
and I'm feeling like I can't get caught
up on my work and my writing or my my
video content so it's a it's every
single day feels like I'm just never
doing things perfectly or as well as I
want to so it's tough to feel like you
are always just gonna have to be good
enough at each of those worlds they are
always being pulled in both very
opposing directions and so you know not
only is that physically and emotionally
exhausting but I think one of the big
problems around this is just that
feeling of overwhelming i am i doing
enough am i doing enough for my kid
am I being a good enough mother and I
think that there's so much judgment of
working moms especially those who maybe
have helped in raising their kid because
that you know there's the idea that you
know your baby is not being raised by
you you're not forming that attachment
to your child that someone else is maybe
going to be the first to see those first
steps or to teach that first word and
that's like a really heartbreaking
thought that you know
I miss something like that that I might
be absent and and that I'm gonna be
judged hard for that not only by
everybody else but also by myself so
like so many millennial moms I'm on a
lot of Facebook support groups and as
much as these are being great at helping
me figure out what diaper cream to use
sometimes they make me feel like total I
mean there's a lot of moms on here who
are real active advocates of like
attachment parenting and the idea that
you know you know nobody else but mom
can really be the one to take care of
baby especially in those first few
months you want to form that bond and
and I've heard a lot of moms tell
stories about how they could not even
you know leave their child for four six
months or eight months or ten months not
even to get like a pedicure and Here I
am letting you know having child care
since pretty much day one someone to
help me so that I can also
simultaneously run my business and we
kind of do this dance throughout the day
and I'm thinking am I being a bad mom am
i making decisions that I'm going to
regret in the long run am i damaging my
child
am I not forming a bond am i spending
too much time with my baby am i spending
not enough time with my baby what about
my career am i letting that go am i
letting that slide there's so many
questions unanswered and well I guess
I'll just kind of have to negotiate
those over time what I do know is that
you know I'm making the best choice that
I can for me right now and I'm lucky I'm
so grateful that I can make that choice
because I know that so many moms out
there just don't have necessarily that
option to willingly make those those
choices you know some moms just cannot
wait to get back into the workforce but
for whatever reason it just financially
makes more sense for them to be at home
because they can't afford daycare they
can't afford you know a nanny or any
other kind of help and then on the flip
side there are women who
really really want to stay home but they
have to go back to work that their Matt
leave is up and they've got to get back
in there because they need to make make
that financial financially work for
their family and I'm just really really
lucky that I've been able to to make
that choice even though it's not an easy
choice that's never feels easy no day
feels easy it's always a struggle but at
least it's something that I willingly
chose to do so one of the things that I
was not prepared for was how emotionally
and physically exhausting mothering is I
mean I love love love being a mom but
mothering is so so hard and I remember
before I you know gave birth I had this
like idealistic idea of what being a mom
was going to be and I thought you know
stay-at-home moms you got it made it is
it's got to be so fun you get to play
with the baby all day you don't have to
go to work you get to be at home you get
to cook it just seemed like a dream and
the reality is I have so much respect
for stay-at-home moms now because it is
so much work and you know I hear from
other moms who are on that leave now
who-who looking back thought they were
gonna get so much accomplished turn not
leave maybe they're gonna start a new
business they were maybe gonna go back
to school they were gonna live it up and
you get to the end of the day and you
just feel so defeated you feel like
you've done absolutely nothing yet you
have done so much you've been on your
feet all day
you've changed a million dirty diapers
you've been done
you've been puked on you've had to pump
and breastfeed a million times you've
had to rock that kid to sleep over and
over again just for them to fall asleep
for five minutes so that you can maybe
go to the bathroom that's literally what
you've been up to
it is such difficult work and yet such
thankless and selfless work and so you
know I have an amazing amount of respect
for these stay-at-home moms and let me
tell you for those of you who have not
experienced it yourself
because I was one of these people and my
husband was one of these people and
we've all had these thoughts
it is so much work it is not just a walk
in the park where you can just watch
soap operas all day that's not what
motherhood looks like and and and I
think we need to give moms so much more
respect and whether you decide to be a
stay-at-home mom or working mom the one
thing I ask is that we support one
another that we can respect one another
and give each other you know as much
props and support as we possibly can
because trust me we're all just trying
to do the best job we can we're all just
negotiating and giving up something
we're all sacrificing something or
different percentages of something and
that sacrifice doesn't feel good no
matter what side you're on so I think
that if we were to just stop judging one
another and stop guilting one another
we'd all being able to be a lot more
effective and efficient and ultimately
happy as moms and they all say you know
a happy mom means a happy baby and
ultimately isn't that what we all want
for our kids so guys I think the bottom
line is the same way that there is no
one-size-fits-all diet here I think the
same could be said for motherhood I mean
there is no best or right way to be a
mom or a parent we're really just all
trying to survive in this really messy
imperfect world of parenthood and do the
best job that we can and ultimately
we're just trying to keep that little
cat alive right so guys I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give it a thumbs up leave me a comment
below about some of the things that you
have felt really guilty about as a mom I
mean hey whether you're a stay-at-home
mom or a working mom we have all been in
this situation so use this as a
situation to get this off your chest and
of course subscribe to the channel if
you don't already and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]